One of the most popular, heartfelt,
and stupid critiques of modern society is that
technology is destroying our civilization.
The plain truth is that technology
isn't enslaving our minds or killing the planet.
It's an extension of who we are as humans.
And massive advances in energy, creation, food production,
computer programming, and industrialization
are the reasons why the planet supports billions of people
who live more prosperously and peacefully,
and why global life expectancy keeps growing.
Humans actually have been getting better
at a lot of things for a long time.
In terms of heading off various diseases,
heading off poverty, and heading off a lot of things.
For the past 60 years, Stewart Brand has been
one of the biggest champions of experimenting
with technology to solve humanity's biggest problems.
You can't count on the past ways of making it better
to fix whatever your current problems are.
You have to keep discovering new ones.
In his early days, he was one of Ken Kesey's
Merry Pranksters, using psychedelics,
music, and light shows to expand consciousness.
By the late 1960s, he started the Whole Earth Catalog,
which quickly became a bible to hippies and techno geeks,
such as Steve Jobs,
who famously quoted its parting message.
Stay hungry, stay foolish.
Dubbed the intellectual Johnny Appleseed
of the counter-culture, Brand's ideas
and activism helped inspire the first Earth Day.
And his early reporting on the personal computer revolution
turned machines that were once synonymous
with centralized, bureaucratic oppression,
into devices of individual empowerment.
His life is the subject of a new documentary film
that takes its name from a famous Brand mantra.
He had the understanding
that humans were on a trajectory
towards greater and technical possibilities.
And he made an important statement.
We are as gods, so we might as well get good at it.
His current passion is Revive & Restore,
an organization that is leading the de-extinction movement
by using biotechnology to bring back
extinct plants and animals.
Including the passenger pigeon, the woolly mammoth,
and the once dominant American chestnut tree.
This is what killed 5 billion American chestnut trees.
These trees are functionally extinct
because they can't reproduce
and make a forest like they used to.
But genetically they're not extinct at all.
They've got all the variety they ever had.
And they're about to get one more bit of variety,
which is one or two genes that'll help them
head off the diseases that we brought here.
Not on purpose.
But the cure is on purpose.
As the film shows, Brand's techno-optimism
isn't without its critics.
I would love to see a mammoth.
Oh, wouldn't that be cool?
That we can do it is so much fun
and so fascinating for people who love technology.
At the same time we ought to be asking, should we do this?
Is this a good idea?
It's a criticism Brand rejects
throughout the documentary.
When genetically modified organisms were first created,
most environmentalists were just automatically against it.
And that actually makes me pretty mad
because that's taking ideology more seriously
than the ecosystems you're trying to protect.
While Brand's vision for de-extinction
has struggled with the very environmental movement
he helped create, he takes solace in
the historic cycles of rejection and acceptance.
When in vitro fertilization first came for humans
there was all the usual resistances.
Hubris, you're playing God,
all those in vitro babies are gonna be sick somehow,
they're gonna be fucked up.
And as soon as you had a couple of in vitro kids
who are adorable, and healthy,
and you had ecstatic parents who could
not otherwise have children, that just flipped.
It just turned off.
And so when we clone now a black-footed ferret,
or Przewalski's horse, people are going,
oh they're adorable animal.
And you say, well it's cloned, you know.
They went, oh really?
Can I do that to my pet?
And it flips.
Yeah, it's more about optimism versus pessimism.
It's more about the world you want to live in
versus the world that you're running from.
The co-directors of "We Are as Gods,"
David Alvarado and Jason Sussberg,
whose previous work profiled transhumanists
experimenting with immortality,
find value in Brand's perspective.
Actually what's more interesting is the use of technology,
the discussion between whether technology
got us to this problem where we have global warming,
where we have an economic system in ruin.
And whether or not we can use technological tools
like Bitcoin, or other sort of financial technology
to get us out of the current mini depression that we're in.
Or using geo-engineering, or other technologies
to get us out of climate change.
I think that it's just really easy
to just say it's technology's fault.
Well, what's the solution here?
What are we talking about?
What is the solution that
that kind of person would be suggesting?
Because I just feel like we need to be
working on it together and building better tools,
which goes right back to the '60s
and what Stewart was talking about.
It's been a long, strange trip for Stewart Brand
and the planet he helped us recognize from outer space,
by goading NASA into releasing images of the whole Earth.
What has kept him on the forefront of what comes next,
from psychedelics, to the internet,
to reviving extinct species, is his undying belief
that technological progress will help us
triumph over our largest problems.
Now in his 80s, Brand still believes in progress.
And the need not just for individuals,
but whole civilizations to keep experimenting,
to keep pushing, to stay hungry, and stay foolish.
Try everything, take nothing off the table.